mom
[Music]
please
[Music]
[Music]
if you woke up this morning and heard
entourage is getting rebooted with a
little bit more diversity so it's five
guys right let's divorce it a little up
black dude Latino do them and three
white dudes right and it's a Netflix
reboot yeah like we just woke up and I
get back
you shall sing [ __ ] and this and instead
of going to CIA the guy want to WME like
like literally like the different re
names Mari like say [ __ ] right darker
Israeli guys exactly like if you heard
that okay so now that show on Netflix
that quality video that show an hour
episode each episode now imagine three
minutes and six seconds from that
episode a clip from three minutes and
six seconds where and where they're just
like they're like wearing your thing or
whatever they're doing just like three
minutes and six seconds from Entourage
2017 if you make that video and put on
Facebook and it works it'll change your
business
[Music]
you're running quads CAC hardcore math
on digital and social and then you're
running TV remnant for brand and it but
the reality is the birth child about the
birth child of that is [ __ ] Facebook
commercials so it's worth killing it so
like as a complete side note like like
so I built so let me tell you why bill
vaynermedia I'm building vaynermedia so
that I can buy Lacoste for 233 million
dollars and run it through my machine
which is why it sounds like you might be
so it's funny well just for the first
time getting into non fortune 100
clients sounds like you're at enough
scale that we should whether it's
whether it's as a client of Vayner
whether it's a veiner sports thing that
gets you access whether it's just me
getting to know you whether it's
advisory shares whether just friendship
like leverage for 50 years I definitely
can tell you this what you do is what I
think about 24/7 365 and there's three
things you should be doing and you're on
to it you're doing it in a department
you're doing it like that
you're doing the math right to the best
of your ability and you're doing brand
that's why you're doing the sports
that's why you're doing TV I'm telling
you right now like children's life on
the table the birth child on Facebook
will check why do you think of hold on
even better
rock group you have to prove that's why
everybody you're off is talking about me
that's what I'm doing
like I laugh at when clients are like
are you sure like why'd you come here
til I tell you I'm like singer
[Music]
my station yeah oh well we're going to
YouTube
[Music]
yeah take a look okay and then all of a
sudden my calendar says one to 120 and
so LA meetings and then they send me an
email saying these are who's there
you got to learn how to Delhi we by the
way when I say you've got to learn I
literally just made this up it's
something I never thought of before but
this is why this is why we can't lose
all we have to do is communicate I love
that you just brought this up right to
me it's having the priorities in the
right place and then we're good you know
what I mean like I can deal with
anything as long as I feel like we're
trying to win the right game you diem
you can understand this business
development opportunity in a long time
probably oak 708 Twitter you know or
early blogging 2002 3 or when tech
leaders had blogs and they put their
email up there and they were actually
answering them you get these moments for
a year or two or three where you get
access to anybody you want that sits on
higher pedestals than you or hot or
interesting and people already tuning
out VM because they're getting bored I
have for the most I'm trying so we've
got six months to a year I'm going to be
sitting regret not using the DM bit
deadly I'm trying to tell them to do
[Music]
I love it
I'm super military - me anytime what do
you think super weight good
all right okay let's find out I also I
also think there's a good place to play
my model right well we make two
commercials but we pick up a shitload of
micro content out of it and we've got a
year's worth of content you know I've
got a couple ideas this whole this whole
this whole thing I'm riding up just to
give you context this whole hashtag
waving like you know Thirsty Thursday or
a motivational Monday or Thursday
thoughts there's things that always
trend and like we can be very smart and
efficient and get a lot of extra organic
so I'll figure it out
but like but like you know the motto
right now for Vayner is you know our our
execution off of reform is very much the
Facebook commercials with influencers
layered on top and some sort of culture
hacking like a like a Alexa voice or
what-have-you so whether it's whether
it's all influencer whether it's whether
it's Rika mercial with 800 pieces of
Michael content that comes out of it I
mean like I'm sitting with G Rock right
now I'm thinking myself like who's isn't
a 22-minute dailyvee like there's
probably three months worth of content
if we really want to see we get like
three days out of it now but like if
there was our only lifeline like so
there's a lot of things we can create in
this environment
[Music]
stuff that you people don't know about
much as we're sharing a vacuum really
getting you're really getting the NBA
I'm how to run [ __ ] what most people
don't understand is is that real a and B
list talent have no time like j.lo does
have time right like Jeter doesn't have
time like like you know Rihanna doesn't
have time and this model is actually
built more for those people than it
isn't in for the entrepreneurs that have
jumped on first right I think it's about
building ultimate brand and attention at
scale which then leads to opportunity I
will tell you this I firmly believe that
fifty percent of the people that would
buy this package would make back their
investment in their advance on a book
deal and on their speaking and that's
when I started getting confident to
actually do it right look max listen
like I know enough about you and you've
been doing some really clever stuff like
I just I just I just think it works for
anybody I mean it's you've got to be
able to afford it and thus and the set
goes into a different stratosphere but
I'm trying to build actual brand in a
world where I think most people you know
what I think happened with me max to be
very frank I think most people are
salespeople and I think I'm a marketer
and a brand er
I built a brand and I didn't cash in in
the short term and so the investment was
worth it and I think there's a lot of
smart individuals out there who realize
suck it up or in a million dollars over
four years get 40% of what Gary got out
of it because of personality differences
and I'll make that ROI positive back
because if you believe what I believe
which is the cellphone is the new
television and Facebook and Instagram
and snapchat and YouTube are ABC NBC and
CBS well then you're trying to become
Seinfeld and some people become Seinfeld
and other people become Charles in
Charge I think I've proven over the last
I think what I understood how content on
the internet works contextual to the
moment in time and the format and the
nuances of the platform right we're not
guessing here we're not just filming and
putting it out like copy creative quotes
like you know as you know it's a good
observation by you and I'm flattered
because I really do respect your POV
like I've upped my game in the last 18
months
hold on a second back Gary Vee I am how
are you my penalty and Nicole how are
you doing to work I'm doing great I'm
student worship are the next day awesome
nowhere else missed ah thank you very
hello
every day brother
Thank You mem love his house yeah [ __ ]
it so much like reality is it doesn't
matter what I did was a little bit
different if you kind of look at the
macro ten years I didn't do any of that
I just want to be unconsumed
MLI of all the weather
[Music]
[Music]
to not think that those features sets
have slowed the momentum of growth in
what I would call the 35 to 55 year old
demo and so I think it's not been a full
year and I think a lot of these things
tend to take a year to understand but I
do think it's kind of like it's on
snapchat now to come back with other
variables so I don't know it's an
intriguing question because I think
people are very naive and don't realize
how strong snapchat is under 30 right
and really under 25 right I mean that's
the punchline who's who says that who
says that snapchat can't create a
feature tomorrow
that really hurts LinkedIn for business
kids under 30 I don't know right so I
think flexibility of content always
matters right so so what about what's
the written word what's the audio what's
the audio look like on snapchat
what if snapchat tomorrow created
unlimited length of a snap in audio I
would tell you the next second I would
put the garyvee podcast on snapchat and
push it like crazy so I'm very
fascinated by audio I think audio is a
place where snapchat could go and say
okay everybody who produces long-form
audio because that's growing on a single
snap you can have unlimited audio I
would be populating my my snapchat
stories so aggressively with long-form
audio and catering into a under 40 year
old demo and that would be huge so
that's one random idea I just made up
they should they should but I'm not it
but I'm not in the business of guessing
I'm in the business of making the right
marketing decisions in the second that
I'm breathing
I don't care
pop
Gary's cool cuz Gary's the course yep
[Music]
just to the finest for the sort of vlog
so that a cool as I'm the most
empathetic and understanding if somebody
can't do something I know you always do
an effort to camera time I know you know
[Music]
plants Helena right pressure sit how's
your day going okay it's super important
like I mean you know but the cliche
thing with agencies is I hate
departments because everybody gets into
their silos but if you don't know what
the [ __ ] is actually happening in a
consumers head it doesn't matter
you're already lost when you go to
create
[Music]
I guess like one thing that I ugly talk
to people about is how you can kind of
communicate between offices among
offices more like house I'm going to
connect people who are like not in the
same place yes
do you have any plans I guess at the
moment for that yes and no so if you
look across every company and so the
great benefit of being an investor a lot
of companies and having a lot of clients
is it's a challenge right there's no
technology
there's no Yammer or slack or whatever
that's going to fix it
and there's no like you know and then
other things like you know buddy systems
or cross pollinating one weeks and other
offices they're really band-aids and the
really optics they make people feel like
the company cares about it I would tell
you a much smarter thing to do and so I
always tell people to communicate to me
is you should send me an email of what
you're yearning for and then let me
create a custom plan I'd rather have a
custom plan for 700 then to check the
box for the entire company that I know
that actually doesn't get done like I'm
not one who does things to appease the
masses to show the optics that we care
I'd rather actually solve it and so
there's 483 people who don't give a [ __ ]
but for the 210 to do I want to figure
it out and so if you feel disconnected
for the rest immediately
I'd rather understand how you feel that
what in detail does it feel like and
then if it's like oh when there are
system changes were two days behind I
want to see the nuances and then try to
solve so these are in a manifesto in one
email now or as it pops up in your head
when you feel it you know awesome such a
pleasure and you have a great day it's
really nice meeting you and you know
it's funny I think everything sensor
like everything that's wrong here is my
fault because that's just how [ __ ] is
but I also think like good things happen
because that so for example I'm scared
shitless of that
I hate that [ __ ] yeah and so I'm not
gonna like it would just [ __ ] me up so
like I love when I hear that from you
because that's like [ __ ] yes like thank
you God
like that's what I want right that's the
honey Empire which is I still want to be
great-looking became like an art direct
and you suck like [ __ ] what do you want
me to do but I don't care if you're
[ __ ] Pablo Picasso if you're a dick
face you're getting the [ __ ] out of here
and I appreciate it also like the candor
I think everybody here is pretty much
like I've been at a job where people had
to like hold back with a really work
shirt here you're like okay bubble boom
you know we'll be in meetings if you
will just be like you know say something
I get they don't [ __ ] get it you
might I mean it's just like you're like
well yeah that's cool for like the
culture here is kind of like I get it
cool I think you I'm yeah and it fits me
as well so it was like a first gig that
every girl makes me happy that makes me
happy brother listen here's why here's
why I had this meeting when [ __ ] doesn't
go as well you emailing all right do you
understand I need a fix yet fifty
thousand feet you know champ and a pad
in handwriting bar going hot touching
down in LAX my price think I'm here to
be it's alright I think we also
overthink a lot of stuff we don't need
to map to the mothership we aren't we
don't have to have our own like it just
could like let's stop overthinking [ __ ]
it's like like you know where are places
I look at you equal to a cm in London as
I do to the head of media in New York
like it's agnostic flat yeah look we're
company yes one two in luck yeah of
course everybody based on their life or
in TV or in paid me I know what humans
do but that's not what it's going to be
some of decisions are being made on
these like when people find money too so
the look
we said freedom ain't free don't be
naive having money doesn't mean you're
any freer tonight the very heady
theoretical and this one has a lot more
practicality and the book by the way
they both matter the problem is the
important one is yours old once the
problem is it's not true until it sees
the light of day and all the creative
world does is debate it prior to the
reality of it coming out which is
inefficient itself it's just very real
to me like I'm so excited yeah I think
I'm going to build the greatest creative
agency of all time out of a theory that
allows creatives to actually have a lot
of that bats to be creative always
follow the rules to play by the book I'm
an academic now with a master's degree
but brothers robbed led more money than
me I guess the nice guys really do
finish so I should have started acting
now I would have gone far cause like you
do in a theme park but now slow and
steady wins the race problems playing to
the finish line
and moved away I'm being don't get it
confused yeah there's a lot more
influencers there's a lot more eyeballs
guys they need people watch a cable
television show 20,000 like a average
team like it's like a lot especially for
you guys cuz you're like young in it you
know like it's you're both like you
can't imagine how much bigger it is than
the real world it's wild fifty thousand
feet in the air not a pen and pad in
handwriting pong going Ron touching down
in LAX my price think I'm here to be a
tourist mom gets smoked the scene
because I wanna be the [ __ ] best
conversation isn't really crazy gorilla
dairy industry with a fan base that it
didn't even faze me misleading the
people they just smoke and mirrors and
for me this is trial and error taking
that tour bus across Beverly Hills I'm
will Dale driver let me tell you saying
crazy bike people spending millions if
he's in and just on the other side same
scene the gang people ducky foolish
gotta stay alive in Hollywood women
flooded thousands on their hair any
constant proper struggling to make is me
on welfare
oh your ideas yeah someone that's almost
like the only thing that Gary Gary do it
is I when I looked at it it was in the
first I stopped doing I'm going to be
doing this yes the first it happen yes I
was like you know student loans I should
have never took always follow the rules
to play by the book I'm an academic now
with the master's degree the brother
drug daily see more money than me I
guess the nice guys really do finished
off I should have started acting now I
would have gone far cause like you do in
a theme park but now slow and steady
wins the race
brother sprains here to finish line and
lose away I'm being paged semi on laying
around the moment and reflect on the
reasons why still exist is my life meant
to be in nine five red eyes promised
myself no more red eyes except for this
year
[ __ ] joke kind of make sure your
actions back up your [ __ ] ma happen
and anyone that tells them that they
can't [ __ ] them in their opinion we only
go on live so we should start living or
we can watch others live there it's your
decision
[Music]